[Musique]
Stéphanie Grandmont Véronique prince
Michel COG bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
je souligne que vous êtes à Sherbrooke
Véronique au caucus de enfin réunion de
QS des candidats et des députés élus ou
élu dans certains cas mais je veux
commencer pour à
Ottawa ce panel
cette commission sur l'état d'urgence
est-ce qu'il était approprié était-il
urgent était-il nécessaire de décréter
l'état d'urgence au fédéral lors de ces
manifestations je vous fais entendre
Paul rouleau juge qui préside cette
commission et Monsieur Trudeau c'est
très rapide en anglais qui répète qu'on
avait besoin d'invoquer cette loi
j'aurais besoin d'entendre beaucoup
d'éléments de preuves dans un cours laps
de temps les audiences offriront un
processus impartial
et exhaustif pour la présentation des
preuves nécessaires afin que la
Commission
puisse donner au public les réponses
auxquelles
il a droit
majeur
Michel c'est faux préciser que la loi
quand on l'invoque oblige cet examen là
par la suite donc parce que comme on
lève un certain nombre de droits
individuels qu'on peut aller chercher de
l'argent dans des comptes plus
facilement etc le législateur a voulu
s'assurer qu'on fait pas ça la légère
d'où la commission 6 semaines qui vont
étudier ça Michel c'est og comment vous
entravoyez l'exercice
d'abord c'est la loi qui succédait à la
loi des mesures de guerre et qui pour
lequel le gouverte obligé de s'expliquer
alors c'est pour ça que cette
explication là deuxièmement il y a deux
mots vous avez prononcé peut-être qui
sont importants c'est pas de savoir si
c'était utile c'est de savoir si c'était
nécessaire est-ce que il y avait
d'autres moyens de lever le blocus des
camionnettes essentiellement que
d'utiliser cette loi là et c'est ça qui
va être intéressant que de voir les
conclusions du jour boulot il y a
personne qui d'autre que c'est utile ça
s'a servi c'est sûr est-ce que c'est le
seul moyen est-ce que c'était la seule
chose à faire de suspendre les libertés
civile et tout ça donc d'invoquer la
nouvelle mouture de la loi des mesures
de guerre ou si on aurait pu faire autre
chose c'est ça qui va être le jugement
du juge ou non c'est ça qui va être
intéressant de constater là ouais
Stéphanie puis je sais qu'on en a
beaucoup parlé lorsque ça se produisait
de tout ça et puis on a soulevé des
questions n'empêche
un certain nombre de de corps policiers
qui ont dit oui c'est utile il y a alors
encore une fois erreur pas utile
nécessaire ou non nécessaire ça va être
le débat existentiel oui mais c'est ça
en fait Michel Le très bien dit la
question 1 ça va être de savoir est-ce
que c'était nécessaire à la sécurité
nationale et ici la preuve sera
peut-être pas si facile que ça à faire
parce que il y a quand même pas eu de
violence on a quand même on a trouvé
c'est vrai des armes un certain moment
donné qui pouvait faire peur j'avoue en
Alberta mais autrement que ça il y a pas
eu de violence et deux deuxième question
c'est est-ce que les provinces c'était
outillées pour faire pour faire le
travail et donc encore là c'est pas
clair que qu'elle va être la réponse
parce que on sait que le pont là à
Windows ils avaient été capable de le
débloquer avant qu'on évoque la loi au
Québec il y avait eu le convoi des des
camionnettes qui avaient le maire là-bas
Bruno marchand avait réussi avec l'appui
de tous les députés à les empêcher de
s'enraciner là devant l'Assemblée
nationale à Québec donc et en plus on a
vu on a entendu aujourd'hui le
gouvernement de l'Alberta dire non nous
on considère qu'on avait les moyens en
place donc cette preuve là évidemment
c'est au fil des jours qu'on va savoir
mais pour l'instant peut-être que c'est
ça semble un peu difficile Véronique
là-dessus parce qu'à Québec
effectivement
marchand mais pas juste marchand le
gouvernement la SQ et tout on s'est
assuré qu'il calme pas là très longtemps
disons non effectivement ça a été par de
la négociation ça a fonctionné alors ici
on a pas eu besoin de se rendre jusqu'à
des mesures comme ça évidemment ce qui
se passe à Ottawa c'est une petite
avertissement de dire ben si on y va
avec des une loi comme ça voici ce qui
vient avec comme conséquence et le
prochain Premier ministre qui voudra
l'appliquer devrait y penser Véronique
je poursuis avec vous vous êtes à cette
réunion de QS d'abord climat général
parce que on l'a beaucoup souligné
depuis
euh depuis la soirée électorale ils ont
pas fait les gains espérés oui il y a eu
des nouveaux il y a des nouveaux députés
mais il y a pas au total une croissance
qu'est-ce qu'on murmure qu'est-ce qu'on
dit quel est l'état d'esprit chez QS je
voudrais que la ligne que tous nous
sortait c'était ben écoutez il y a une
vague kaki quand il y a une déferlante
quand il y a un tsunami c'est difficile
de résister mais nous on s'est tenu
debout en fait on est le seul parti qui
s'est pas écrasé devant cette vague en
même temps qu'on leur demande oui mais
c'est la taxe Orange vous avez été
défini comme adversaire cela en
politique définir son adversaire le
souvent là c'est la clé en campagne
électorale la taxe orange ça fait mal
puis on leur a demandé à quel point ça
leur a fait mal puis on a senti que
là-dessus la réunion se passait à huis
clos je le voulais pas trop en parler
évidemment mais quand même il y en a
deux André Fantasia et Aaron Boisy qui
est un nouveau député qui ont un peu
ouvert la porte en disant
peut-être qu'au niveau de la
communication il y aurait fallu mieux
l'expliquer il demeure tous les deux
convaincus qu'il faut imposer les plus
riches mais à ce qu'ils ont bien
expliqué leur proposition est-ce qu'ils
ont bien choisi le seuil les voulaient
pas s'aventurer sur l'explication le
seuil d'un million de dollars qu'on
aurait dû dire par exemple 2 millions
des fois c'est pas la communication des
fois c'est le fond aussi Stéphanie
Michel C parce que on entend ça depuis
toujours la communication des fois
communiquer quelque chose qui est pas
populaire même si on le communique bien
ça sera pas plus populaire Michel Cyr
non effectivement et le problème c'est
que déjà de la classe moyenne qui ont
pas le train de vie d'un millionnaire
était dans la définition que donnait la
loi orange puisqu'on l'appelle comme ça
maintenant
devenait des millionnaires c'est-à-dire
que vous aviez un petit fond de passion
vous êtes un millionnaire alors ça c'est
pas de la communication c'était le fond
de la terre et si on avait mis le seuil
plus haut tu es ça serait beaucoup mieux
tirer parce que là le vrai problème
politique que US là-dedans c'est qu'ils
ont confirmé tous les préjugés que les
gens pouvaient avoir sur QS
alors ça c'est un pire après peut
arriver en politique et je sais que
plusieurs membres scocus qui disent
c'est pas juste une affaire de
communication alors c'est à voir dans
quelque chose que on avait pas bien
compris puis que qu'il allait pas être
acceptable par beaucoup de gens puis on
le voit dans son âge du moment que la
taxe a été mentionné que ce téléphone
faire la carte utiliser l'expression qui
a collé là quand ça colle parce que il y
a de la colle il y a quelque chose
et puis évidemment augmenter des impôts
dans en campagne électorale c'est pas
nécessairement une stratégie très très
payante
mais aussi oui c'est vrai que ça a été
magnifique que ça aurait été très
difficile à mettre en place entre autres
comment on a évalué les actifs à chaque
année des gens ce qu'on ça aurait été
extrêmement complexe pour le peu
d'argent finalement qu'on serait allé
chercher donc tout ça était était était
amené drôlement mais je pense comme
Michel que il y a ça ça fait ressortir
la vraie nature de Québec solidaire
parce que peut-être que des gens avaient
pas réalisé à quel point c'est quand
même un parti qui est à gauche et puis
quand on regarde leur programme pas leur
plateforme qu'ils ont présenté aux
élections mais leur programme on
que c'est quand même un parti qui a des
idées pas mal radicales les questions de
nationaliser les banques en partie les
questions de bon alors toutes sortes de
choses
c'est dans pas le programme mais c'est
dans le n'était pas dans la plateforme
mais c'est dans le c'est ça c'est dans
le programme donc ok un mot autour de
table rapide où on en est dans ses
négociations ces discussions Québec
soldat qui va être reconnu comme un
parti à l'Assemblée nationale Véronique
évidemment le Parti québécois aussi
madame anglais doit être d'accord est-ce
que ça évolue ça depuis quelques jours
Véronique pas tellement mais la pression
augmente par exemple parce que Gabriel
nado Dubois a fait une tournée
d'entrevue hier il y en a parlé encore
aujourd'hui en disant la vraie Dominique
Anglade en clin d'oeil à l'expression
qu'elle utilisait elle-même est-ce que
c'est cette femme qui ne veut pas
rassembler qui ne veut pas collaborer
qui veut pas laisser de la place aux
autres donc il essaie de la dépeindre
finalement comme une femme qui n'est pas
aussi sympathique le prétend dans le
fond c'est il essaie de faire coller
cette image là et ça peut accentuer la
pression c'est sûr que Québec solidaire
dit en 2018 on l'avait eu le statut puis
on était pratiquement le même nom ils
étaient 10 sont rendus 11 alors eux
voient pas pourquoi il pourrait pas
obtenir à nouveau ce statut-là pour le
Parti québécois c'est autre chose son
rendu 3 mais en même temps que avec
solidaire dit on a déjà été trois on
pourrait reconnaître aussi une forme de
statut pour le PQ on est prêt à
collaborer donc il met la porte au PQ
parce que ça avait été
soit mal compris ou m'a expliqué là je
sais pas mais on avait eu l'impression
qu'il y avait dit le PQ tant pis pour
eux mais c'est pas ça qui a dit là non
non en fait aujourd'hui ils ont dit à
Québec solidaire avec amirc à dire
justement à cette époque là on avait
déjà été trois et on avait eu des
aménagements donc ça serait vraiment
malvenu pour nous pas donner ces
aménagements là ce qui m'amène
directement à ce sondage publié dans le
Journal de Montréal ce matin très
intéressant sondage Léger
monsieur le goût avait dit au début de
la campagne s'intéresse personne la
réforme du mode du cru on se bat pas
dans les autobus pour ça ce qui est
certainement vrai qu'on se bat pas dans
les autobus pour ça mais le sondage
Léger je vous le montre il y a quand
même 53% des Québécois qui se disent
souhaiter une réforme actuelle du mode
du scrutin et là évidemment on a
tellement parlé depuis lundi à 10 jours
12 jours que mais quand même 53 27 noms
20 ne sait pas ce qui est intéressant
c'est le prochain tableau c'est ceux qui
payent un prix fort du système actuel
qui sont davantage pour la CAQ les
militants de la CAQ se disent contre
QS 75% pour 73 partis québécois 60 et
libéraux et le Parti conservateur qui
paye le gros prix le cas 0 député
79 pour
est-ce que je vous pose la question très
simplement ce que ça change quelque
chose dans les prochains mois est-ce que
ça peut faire réfléchir monsieur le goût
ou pas du tout Stéphanie
mais en tout cas c'est sûr que Monsieur
Lego qui disait que c'est intéressant
seulement les intellectuels finalement
on a 53 % d'intellectuel au Québec et
ces deux fois plus que des gens qui sont
qui sont en défavor d'une réforme bon ça
donne quand même de l'eau au moulin pour
ceux qui souhaiteraient une réforme du
mode de scrutin mais est-ce que ça va
être suffisant je doute que ça se fasse
dans un avenir rapproché par contre une
réforme de du règlement des règles
parlementaires ça je pense que ça
devient essentiel vous en parler de tout
à l'heure avec avec Véronique et puis là
on se rend compte qu'à chaque élection
c'est c'est de plus en plus ridicule on
est toujours obligé de renégocier à la
pièce avec les avec les parties pour
leur accorder un statut qui reflète la
position qui mérite donc ça je pense que
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui devrait
pouvoir se faire ouais ça c'est ça ça
s'arrange plus facilement la
représentativité à l'Assemblée nationale
le nombre de questions par mois le un
sujet etc vers un ex sur le mode de
scrutin
je pense pas que ce sont d'âge là enfin
je sais pas je vous pose la question on
va faire changer d'idée monsieur le
Gaulle non pas du tout ça le fera pas
changer d'idée parce que justement il
préfère y aller avec une réforme
parlementaire et négociait la pièce
parce que ses yeux c'est beaucoup plus
simple que de réformer un mode de
scrutin ce serait de se lancer dans une
opération quand même assez complexe on
voit ce que ça fait dans d'autres pays
par exemple en Israël il veut vraiment
pas se lancer là-dedans et le pari que
son équipe fait c'est que oui là il
apprenne la chaleur ça va durer encore
peut-être quelques semaines mais dans
six mois ils disent qu'ils vont encore
parler du mode de scrutin quand on va
être rendu dans les affaires courantes
là la prochaine fois qu'on va en
reparler c'est peut-être à l'élection
2026 mais d'ici là on va faire le reste
de notre agenda puis en attendant on va
continuer de dire qu'on a pas
l'intention de se lancer là-dedans on va
continuer d'encaisser la critique puis à
mon moment donné mais les gens vont
arrêter dans le parler d'en parler c'est
ça le pari qui font parce que je signale
je vous donne la parole Michel
le sondage était fait du 7 au 10 octobre
donc c'est vraiment tout en allumer
radio télé tout le monde parlait de ça
là c'est comme tout le monde était
devenu des experts en Sciences Po Michel
deux choses 30% seulement des électeurs
de la carte veulent les changements du
mode de scrutin je peux vous dire tout
de suite que 100 % des députés de la
carte veulent pas alors donc ça se
probablement moi je suis devenu ciné là
ça se prend pas de mon vivant face à ce
reproduire du vivant Véronique non plus
je dis à la fin ça c'est long
mais mais à la fin à chaque fois qu'on
propose ça le caucus du parti au pouvoir
défait l'affaire
les libéraux que ça vient d'arriver pour
la claque et ils électeurs de la carte
demande pas ça monsieur Lebeau s'il y a
une chose à laquelle il fait attention
c'est qu'est-ce que ça base électorale
veut et s'il y a juste 30% des gens de
la base électorale de la carte qu'ils
veulent c'est signe que ça se repose
bon très bien le
climat est-ce que c'est ça sera parce
qu'on avait un extrait comme il reste de
temps ce panel
Véronique le climat est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que QS je boucle la boucle
avec Us va prendre ça sera le leur
grosse sujet ils veulent des États
généraux ils veulent qu'on organise
quelque chose bientôt
au niveau du mode de scrutin
effectivement eux vont continuer du
climat
en fait moi ce que j'ai trouvé spécial
aujourd'hui c'est que c'était vraiment
une stratégie c'est une tactique de
Gabriel Nadaud Dubois parce que je vous
rappelle que la semaine dernière
François Legault a tendu la main en
disant moi je suis prêt à travailler sur
la question de l'environnement avec
Québec solitaire aujourd'hui Québec
solidaire dit ah ouais parfait on va la
prendre la main tendue mais on a des
conditions par exemple on aimerait avoir
un sommet sur le climat une semaine
national on aimerait que vous nous
arriviez dans la première avec dans la
première année avec un nouveau plan sur
le climat et ça coince un peu François
Legault parce que il peut pas tout de
suite fermer la porte en disant mais là
parce que c'est pas sûr que je suis en
train de vous proposer donc je pense que
dans les prochains jours François
Legault va dire attendez qu'on nomme le
ministre de l'Environnement on va y
penser mais moi j'ai pas l'impression
que la claque s'en va vers ça parce que
le sommeil il y a deux écoles de pensée
il y a ceux qui disent ça permet de
trouver un consensus d'apaiser des
tensions puis à l'autre école de pensée
des gens qui disent ça sert juste à
gagner du temps pendant son long on agit
pas je pense que François Legault va se
ranger là-dedans disant nous on préfère
agir plutôt que de tenir un sommet donc
j'anticipe ce genre de réponse là dans
les prochains jours ça vous rappelle des
souvenirs Michel les sommets comme moi
il y a eu des grands sommets au Québec
prenez l'évêque on a fait ce Bouchard en
a fait monsieur Legault même se mettre
l'éducation qui a été ministre
l'éducation
mais je pense que ça a eu énormément de
résultats c'est ça mais là dans ce
cas-ci plus que jamais l'environnement
et l'anglement de la CAQ c'est normal
que que c'est leur sujet
merci à vous trois c'est ma faute j'ai
mal mesuré l'horloge merci au revoir à
très bientôt pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI